Well, that's actually something we can easily compute.
The product of these two is 4 minus the product of these two.
This is zero so we have 4 minus 0, which is 4.
The square root down here is the product
of all the individual row and column sums.
So this is 2 x 2 x 2 x 2, which is 16.
The square root of 16 is also 4.
So we have value of 4 up here,
value of zero down here,
value of 4 down here.
Four minus zero divided by 4 is precisely 1,
which means that we do have a strong correlation between
failure and coverage.
Here we have the product of the first diagonal
minus the product of the second diagonal,
and here we have the square root over the product
of the individual sums of the rows and columns.
Let's fill the appropriate values of our table and compute the Phi coefficient.
We click on run, and we get 1.0.
Always nice to see that the computer confirms what we already had thought.